today is May seventh so it's about time
that I do another dr. Sandler channel
update to fill people in on what
happened during the very very very busy
month of April and to talk a bit about
what's coming up in May or rather in
part what's happened in May already and
the rest about what's coming up so let
me just jump right in to April a lot of
events a lot of speaking engagements
which is which is great but it took you
know along with having classes and
everything else it really kept me busy
so there were two conferences that I
went to and presented papers at both of
them were about both of the papers were
about seeing and some the first one is
actually at st. Anselm's college it was
the the fifth and they do these every
two or three years st. and some
conference hosted by the Institute for
st. Anselm's studies with who might have
a long-term affiliation it's a great
great organization at a great school and
I presented a paper on handsome and
married life which I'm eventually
expanding into an article that I'm going
to be sending out for publication
hopefully later on this summer the other
one was at felician college at the
rutherford campus in new jersey and
there i presented a paper a little bit
more esoteric about a physical content
it was about Anselm is a Neoplatonism of
degrees of being and whether justice
could be considered to be a degree of
being so if you're interested in those
those sorts of things the videos are
available I link to it in the
description of this video I also did a
doctor sailor philosophy forum with my
friend Morris term these are Google
Hangouts on air that I've been doing
first on my own and then with with
guests and you can't it's not like a
regular Google hangout you can't
participate in it you know by it by
being involved with with video yourself
you know so that you're on the screen
but you can't ask questions make
comments and we try to address them as
we're doing it it's a live event
you can also see the footage of it what
else oh I did a talk with with some
students from The Culinary Institute of
America during one of the class sessions
I came in as a guest lecturer they had
read Daniel Boulud letters to a young
chef and they'd also read real case
letters to a young poet which is which
is a work that I'm particularly
interested in I'm interested in you know
balloon as well but i really love real
king and i talked with them about some
of the key themes there's actually a lot
of back and forth so if you're
interested in that one video for that is
available as well I did a talk with a
local group that is so secretive so you
know organic that they they don't want
me to mention their name so i won't i
did a talk about mindfulness and how a
lot of what we call mindfulness today we
can find many of those those ideas in
ancient philosophy and clay in the
classic philosophical tradition in the
West not just an Eastern philosophy but
also in the West and then Western
philosophy provides us you know
particularly with like Plato or
Aristotle or epictetus with a nice
framework for making sense on what it
exactly we want mindfulness for what
mindfulness is actually supposed to
contribute so that was that was kind of
nice i I'm going to talk about the
glimpses into existence series the
existentialism series i've been doing at
the library but we pushed the april one
into May because of the weird calendar
you know month thing because of that
Easter so that'll you know come up a
little bit later I also did 22 well not
just to radio shows I I contributed to
to radio show so I'll put it to you that
way there's theology matters with the
pillows and I've been a guest on there
before I came on again actually I've
been involved with something that kept
me busy on thursday night so i wasn't
able to
do those for quite a while and now I'm
able to so I did one in in April and I
talked about Augustin on truth and lying
and it was it was a really fun show so
if you wanna that one there's no video
footage if you want to hear it there's
i'll give you a link to the podcast in
the description i also did more work
with the punk rock philosopher this is a
guy down in Texas who is really into
continental philosophy also he's also
interested in some some classical things
as well and he does a really
extraordinary job picking out musical
selections mixing them in with some
discussion about themes and say
Nietzsche or this month it was really a
lot of Dostoevsky and i'll be doing more
stuff with him he also worked with
Morris and did some stuff on uncon so
that's really kind of a fun offbeat kind
of how would you describe it that's
something very unusual I don't see
anybody else doing that sort of thing
out there on the air so you know you
might give it a listen it's it's really
interesting stuff I was busy with
classes my marist classes are now coming
to a close I've been teaching ethics
which I've taught for a long time I've
been teaching religion in America which
used to be a staple class of mine and i
taught at this semester for from marist
using a textbook that that is new to me
in the sense that i've never used it as
a textbook but i'd read it before and
I've been busily developing this
existentialism class 40 plaire know
which is going to be an online three
credit course once I have all the
materials that i want developed for some
a little bit of perfectionist about this
then i submit it to Claire know and they
you know give me a little they either
give me a thumbs up or they say well you
need to put in a little bit more of this
or take out
to that and then they give me the thumbs
up and it's great to be offered so
something that a lot of viewers have
been asking me about you know when are
you gonna they've always been asked me
what are you going to do a MOOC i'm not
going to do a move but i am going to do
a class which you can sign up for there
is there is tuition for it but you also
get credit for it because a player no
has sought and we had gotten
accreditation from the state of Vermont
and they're now working with the
regional accrediting body to get that as
well so yeah I've been doing a lot of
work with that that turns out to you
know take quite a bit time you notice
that I've done a lot of video work this
is last month the half hour Hagel series
I've been continuing with that I made a
firm commitment that I'm going to get
through the entirety of the work even
though it's probably going to take about
two years you can see the conference and
talk videos I've linked to those in the
description and there's a lot of
religion in America videos from from the
class those are going to be drawing to a
close so now that was a good time for me
to shift to May and why don't I actually
just spring into what I'm going to be
doing in terms of videos so the religion
in America course I've shot almost all
of the videos for the semester that are
going to be shot I only have one more to
do I haven't released the mall yet
because I you know takes time to edit
them and format things properly and I
also don't want to overload my viewers
but probably by the end of this this
next week those will be finished up with
I would like to go back and revisit a
lot of that material and I might do
another you know whole lecture series on
religion in america at a later date but
i'm not going to worry about that this
summer half-hour Hagel you're going to
see quite a few more
those I'm going to try to step it up to
doing about two maybe even three a week
in part because you know if I do three a
week then it won't take quite so long to
actually get through the entire book
it's quite a creative project I laid
myself in for with that but above very
worthwhile 1 i'm getting a lot of good
feedback from from viewers who are
finding the series useful engaging and
that's really what I want out of it I'm
going to do some more the 10 shorts
videos I haven't done those for a little
while in part because I've been so busy
with other projects and commitments but
I've got you know people asking me
questions so it's about time for me to
do some more of those videos it made you
a few other personally oriented videos
but the bulk of what I'm going to be
doing is actually catching up on lecture
videos for the existentialism course
because in the employer no course I'm
not using them as course videos because
will actually be having class sessions
through video conferencing every week
but I am providing them as supplementary
lecture videos so I need to get some
shot on de Beauvoir I need to get some
shot on Kafka I need a few more ones on
Sartre and probably on Heidegger trying
to think of who else I probably could
use some more on Dostoevsky so there's
there's a number of different ones that
I need to shoot once classes are
finished with my face to face classes
that opens up a lot more time for me to
get that sort of stuff done I don't have
as many events during May I'm going to
be doing two of the glimpses well I've
done one of the glimpses into existence
library talks at the kingston library on
existentialism very well attended it was
on nietzsche and we talked about a lot
of the general themes of his work later
this month the 31st I believe of May
saturday 1030 at the kingston public
library i will be talking about Rilke
another great existentialist a German
language poet also novelist erode novel
and letter writer a lot of his letters
have some some amazing metaphysical
stuff in them so that's coming up i'll
be doing another dr. Sadler philosophy
forum I think I'm a this month do one
without a guest and just decide to do
something on my own I haven't picked the
topic yet I might actually make it focus
on existentialism since hopefully the
class on existentialism I know the class
will be finished I don't know that a
planner will be ready to release it and
start enrolling students by the end of
May but you know it could happen so yeah
that'll that'll be kind of kind of good
what else so class wise like i said i'm
working on the ax player no class my
Maris classes are drawing to a close
they have their their final exams and
you know we have like one more class
session left in the semester I haven't
been doing much with learnist and
curious but I'm going to be working on
putting some more content into those
platforms and i'm looking at a rather
we're looking at reason I oh that's
that's the company that my wife and I
have that we do all of this under we're
going to be looking at some some
platforms for developing some classes of
our own in addition to doing the the
employer no classes and some of the
other platforms I'll be doing another
theology matters towards the end of the
month I'll put a link to that as well
that one will be on evil and Augustine's
views on on it he sees evil as a
privation of the good and so that's kind
of a we
concept what does that actually mean
well we'll talk all about that and I'm
going to do some more interactive work
with the punk rock philosopher he's a
interested in hegel ties it nicely with
the half-hour Hagel classes so we'll do
some stuff on the preface to the
phenomenology I don't know maybe we'll
mix in some master-slave dialectic stuff
as well because people always like that
but we'll see and another thing i'm
doing it may is i'm working on a
proposal and finishing up a sample
chapter for a textbook I've been you
know i'm at the point in my career where
I get a lot of people wanting me to come
in and work you know for them on
projects or collaborate with them on
projects i have another thing that I'm
doing on the side that I I don't want to
say too much about at this point because
it's not quite ready to release but I'll
tell you this it has to do with critical
thinking and when it comes out the guy
who is working on it whose brainchild it
is this is really going to be an
interesting useful website platform tool
for for helping people do critical
thinking but I'm doing all that sort of
stuff in any case you've got a lot of
academic and more organizational
commitments I'm doing some other writing
like I said I'm trying to take some of
these papers that I've written and turn
them into two things that can be sent
out as articles still working on the
book I danced on the moral theory i want
to start digging into that a bit more
I've got a lot of notes but they need to
be formulated into actual pages of
writing same thing with my Aristotle and
anger book been taking a lot of notes
been thinking a lot about his theory of
anger and other people's theories and
the phenomenon that we experience with
it but I have not actually been sitting
in from the computer doing the sort of
tippity tap stuff that that needs to
happen in order for it to become a
manuscript so I need to I need to hunker
down and get to
and once classes are over that becomes a
lot a lot easier so a lot going on in
may not as much out there more in the
studio more on my computer more up in my
head April was extremely busy very happy
to have had the chance to get to talk
with as many people and interact with
people and and bring philosophy out
there beyond just you know the ivory
tower walls of academia and get get
other people interested in reading these
texts and thinking about these these
these great writers so that wraps it up
for the updates if there's anything else
maybe i'll post it in a comment or
something like that as an addendum